want to ask you guys to think about the
last time you were dealing with a really
challenging problem right something
you're really stuck on you're working it
through and then you start kind of
figuring it out and you figure it out
and it starts to click and you get then
you're like oh yeah and you get that
like hell yeah type of feeling like that
Euphoria of like you finally solved it
that is the love the really great data
products build they bring that out in
people right so when you have something
that's really amazing where you help
them solve that problem it makes folks
really excited and so what I'd like to
talk today a little bit about is how do
we actually how do we create that right
how do we create data products that
customers really love
and so there's two really important
factors that we need to consider as the
Builders of data products that go into
this
so first and foremost we have to have
the right focus and we'll talk a lot
more about what that means and we need
to have well executed handoffs and this
part I think is one of the most
overlooked aspects of building data
products
excuse me
so the goal of this talk but we're going
to introduce a framework and we're going
to go through some tips for how to build
really great data products this talks
for you if you're at if your company
builds data products or incorporates
data into your products if you're a data
practitioner and if that's not you I'm
pretty curious about your own curiosity
come say hi and tell me why you're here
because I'd love to know
um but yeah so after some intros we're
going to clarify a few terms and then
really going to focus on these three
core data products there are three types
of data products I should say talk about
the framework and then how to ensure
that we're building really great
products
um this is the abbreviated lightning
Talk version of you have the full
version up on here feel free to uh I'll
be putting it up there you can download
it from there
uh so hi I'm Rick or Ricky either one
works uh my pronouns are he and him I'm
currently senior vice president of data
at entera.ai but I've been working in
data for nearly two decades and I spent
the last 10 years or so building data
teams and building data products
um and prior to that I was head of data
strategy and insights at a company
called The Farmer's dog if you saw the
Super Bowl this year you saw that really
amazing commercial that won all the
beautiful Awards absolutely love with
everything that's happening there uh
before that I was uh head of data at
video it was acquired by gamma and the
orchard acquired by Sony at the orchard
we were an early adopter of a small
little database company called snowflake
we put together the looker snowflake
stack and helped make that thing happen
um so let's clarify a few terms because
these are important uh the thing on the
left is not the same thing as the thing
on the right uh they sound very similar
they look very similar they are very
different
managing data as a product is not the
same as data product management managing
data as a product is giving data the
respect it deserves and managing those
actual assets at least that's what it is
to me data product management is about
solving problems for your customers and
you happen to be doing so by use of data
so
um first of all what are the who are
these customers of data products if
you're putting data right into a
front-end tool customers are accessing
it through charts or graphs numbers what
have you that's pretty simple it's the
folks on the other end of that but it's
also your internal customers as well so
your partner oops I'm going the wrong
way your partners in finance marketing
supply chain operations all those folks
um but left to answer this really
important question right what is data's
purpose why do we have data Council why
are we all here why do we work in this
industry right and I'd say at the heart
of it right data is there to help us
move on to something else where they are
unblocking a decision that we cannot get
through we're stuck and data helps us
get unstuck right and I think that is
its core purpose it gets us unstuck from
something that's actually really
challenging
um and so you know a lot of folks say oh
data's about outcomes many right at the
end of the day I think everything's
about outcomes right why do you work in
supply chain no it's about outcomes
right it's always about outcomes but how
do you actually get there
um and for me it's decisions and actions
right so data leads to decisions
decisions lead to actions actions lead
to outcomes
um topic for another discussion is is
there really a difference between
decisions and actions I would say that
there's no such thing as a decision if
there's not an action following it
um you know it would love to have that
discussion I don't actually know that
but I use the term decisive action to
essentially capture both of those terms
together because to me they're one and
the same uh I heard before that music
and dancing are really wanting the same
as well but I like that decisive actions
um so how does data actually impact
outcomes two core ways better decision
quality faster time to decisions
right so I have the opportunity to make
a choice between a b c and d on my own I
would have chosen C because I think
that's a great choice I look at the data
and I realize oh option b is actually a
much better choice all right I'm going
to do that so I'm making a better
decision because I have data or
conversely or similarly I'm able to
actually make that same decision even
faster right so I would have reached the
conclusion on my own but because I have
data I'm able to get there faster or
with more confidence so actually get to
action a lot faster
this is super important data does not
produce outcomes itself it is a humbling
thought but
um and from one point of view I'm
stating the obvious but this becomes
really important later on right we have
to really understand and embrace this
idea that there is no value in data
itself right and we need to actually
have some other part that comes with it
afterwards
so let's talk about data products
um I would argue that there's really
only three kinds of data products
um and this is not about categorizing
things like uh in taxonomy or what have
you this is about in understanding what
your date what product You're Building
you can really focus in on what is the
right way to build it what is the right
product to build
right so let's say data data products
solve one of three problems
problem number three and I I have a
little bit of a hierarchy here but
problem number three is our data needs
to be accessed and managed right
data lives over here people and systems
are over here we either need to bring
the data to the people or we need to
build a road from the people and the
systems to the data whatever it is we
need to somehow put those things
together and then we need to govern it
and we need to manage it we need to know
how to actually use it and what does it
mean and all these other aspects that
are really really important right and so
we're managing the the connections
between the data the access data we need
to make it faster and then it grows and
we need to make it scale and then it
gets expensive so then we need to manage
costs there's a whole lot that goes into
this these are all the access and
management problems
um
but then we have data that doesn't even
exist yet right either we fail to
observe it when we could have observed
it or we can't observe it because it's
in the future and it hasn't happened yet
or we can't observe it because it's
latent and we can't directly observe it
emotions is one of my favorite data
points right how do you actually put
data into how do you put emotions into a
database
and so we need to create data that
doesn't exist this has classically been
called data science
um but I think it's really about
creating data oops skipping through very
fast so sorry about that and then the
number one problem we're solving with
data is this decisions are really hard
to make
I would say that if we had perfect
information and we knew where we wanted
to get to decisions would be incredibly
easy to make right you could take you
know exactly what's going to happen you
know exactly what your outcomes you want
decisions become easy decisions only
become hard because there's a lack of
information because we don't know
everything we need to know to make that
decision
so again data products solved one of
these three core things so decisions are
hard to make we don't have the data we
need data we have is hard to manage
and from data we get to decisions we get
to actions that's how we get to outcomes
so if we know we want to build these
products to help make these decisions
easier to take
which are the right products to build
and I think a data as this uh I don't
know where this idea came from but this
infinite Swiss army knife right do you
remember Swiss Army knives these have
like those just like four little things
and they got like bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger but you could do
anything with it right someone comes to
you it's like oh can we can you solve
this problem with data yeah of course
you can right you can solve almost
anything with infinite resources
infinite time but when you have the
constraints of reality that becomes a
lot more challenging so you really need
to figure out which are the right
products to build
and so the most important thing if
you're going to be building a data
product is this you really need to
understand what are the decisions your
customers are making
and it always has to be about this for
anything you do in data and even and
maybe especially data engineering
right so meaning like it's a little bit
harder in the sense that uh from data
engineering we're way farther removed
from the decisions but still even in
data engineering
um you know working real estate data at
the moment if you bring in we're
bringing in data let's say once every
three hours right what if we bring it in
once every 24 hours so we're bringing in
once every hour what does that do to the
decision that we're making with that
data right is that important do we want
you to switch to streaming data well are
you going to make better decisions by
having instantaneous data right and that
and you really have to go all the way
from that chain of events from I have
this data faster earlier better what
have you to how does that change the
decision I'm making with the data or not
me my customers who's ever making the
decisions
um so this is a summary of the framework
there's a lot of important stuff here
again we'll put it up on the site
um a lot of core Parts here about
understanding the decision frequency
understanding how the data itself
impacts the decision right what decision
would you make without the data if
you're going to make the exact same
decision with or without the data don't
bother building that data product right
that's a really important concept there
but I want to focus for right now just
on these three things that we need to
identify so we need to identify the
decisions we need to identify the
opportunities and we need to identify
the handoffs
how do you identify decision points
this is a little bit harder than it
sounds right so we talk about so I've
been talking about focusing on decisions
focusing on decisions it's actually not
that easy
um but very obvious thing is you can ask
you won't always actually get those
answers right or you might get some of
the answers but not all of them you can
observe that's actually the best which
is actually to be able to watch your
customers do their job or do whatever it
is that they do in their day and you
will actually see those decision points
and what do decision points look like
I would argue they look like in action
right so you look at somebody anytime
they get stuck I would say there's an
opportunity for a data product right
right procrastination I would argue has
nothing to do with time management
procrastination is a lack of focus and a
lack of clarity both of which data can
solve really really well right and so if
you watch someone work and you look at
the things that they're not doing that
you know they want to be doing or should
be doing those are the opportunities for
data products
and so you find the inaction and you
find the decision points
and then the other thing is they'll
actually come to you sometimes right
those problems will come to you but
they'll come to you as Solutions and
someone will say can you give me this
report can you put this into your
product can you add this feature yeah of
course we can can you help me understand
a little bit more what do you want to do
with this oh can you give me a chart
that shows me a line graph like this
sure absolutely line graph is going to
go like this like this like this right
so when it goes like that what decision
are you going to do with it if it goes
like that what decision are you going to
do you're going to be staring at this
chart what do you do afterwards and
really having those conversations with
your customers
oops
um yeah and so that's identifying
decisions identifying opportunities uh
oops it's not going there we go um so
again we talked about improving decision
quality improving time to decisions
briefly talking about improving decision
quality lots of questions you can ask
about it the one question I really want
to focus everyone in on is this core
question what is preventing a better
decision from happening today
and when you ask that question you're
going to get an answer I promise you you
ask anyone making a decision they'll
give you a really simple answer
and what you should do is follow that
question up with a very simple great
what else and they'll give you you know
maybe something else keep asking and
what else and what else and what else
you asked that about 12 13 times until
they're like no that's it you sure just
wait show them write it all up on a
board
if you like anything else and just sit
there quietly they'll come up with
something else and usually it's that
last thing they come up with which is
the most important thing right and so
just keep asking that
and that's where you identify the
opportunities so identify decisions the
opportunities
this one right here
um I think is probably the most
overlooked one and I will say handoffs
is where data products go to die
I had a wonderful conversation with Jeff
earlier this week about
amazing data science models that
did some really fantastic Cutting Edge
stuff on the math side got put you know
got build up sent to folks nothing
happened with them they just sat on a
shelf right why do they sit on a shelf
because we haven't figured out the
handoffs right we really need to
identify so we talked before about data
having no inherent value it's a very
humbling feeling a humbling idea to
realize that there is nothing that we do
that inherently has value itself the
value is in connecting with other people
it is when we make those connections at
the handle that the value happens and so
that's what we need to do so we really
need to identify who specifically is
going to act what do they know about it
right what are they expecting what's
their timeline right I'm getting into
this really really deep I don't have
time to go to go too deep into this
right now anyone who wants to chat about
this this is probably one of the most
important parts to actually getting a
data product productionalized and being
used right
um yeah and the more details you get on
this like the more you identify about
this before you start building the
better the thing you're going to build
so a few quick tips for building some
really great products here
um first of all front-end data products
they have two design processes
recognizing that there are two different
design processes and they're completely
different and completely different skill
sets will really help a ton here right
imagine tons of analogies here
um but really data design is like
writing a book product design is like
publishing a book right very different
skill sets similarly you wouldn't have
your cardiologist your brain surgery you
wouldn't have your neurologist do your
heart surgery right you want to make
sure that you have the right folks for
the right type of design that you're
doing
um
yeah data design telling the story
product design interacting with the
story both very very important right not
downplaying either of them but they're
very different skill sets
another tip make sure to take
responsibility for our work getting used
this is the most important thing we are
responsible for our work getting used to
talk to so many data practitioners like
I'm going to give you the data what you
do with it that's up to you
I say no I'm going to give you the data
I'm responsible make sure you can use it
that you know how to use it right sure
once I hand it off to you I'm not going
to crack a whip and make sure you're
using it but I'm going to make sure that
I'm planning correctly at the beginning
so that I know how you will use it once
you receive it
um and then as far as data science
um we could talk I give a whole talk
just on this part alone right the
biggest obstacle data science is to Sea
of possibilities you can do absolutely
anything with it that will actually kill
it because you could do anything with it
so I've implemented this uh what I call
the two-day rule sorry for the cheeky
pun right but moving along moving away
from the can we do it to what can we do
in two days
and what I mean by that is any single
data science project that you're
starting for the first time absolutely
time box it to a small of time as
possible so for me that's two days right
like nothing should be done and like
nothing should be planned that will take
longer than two days if you're already
planning for it to take longer it's
going to keep creeping and creeping and
creeping so what can you get done in two
days second iteration third iteration
sure give it like a month or two right
but the first time two days only
um also this is really important so I
was talking to to to uh John from the
African uh data Foundation or let
downstairs data's full of bias use it
responsibly be aware of the bias in your
data whatever you build is going to have
that same bias make sure you're aware of
that be responsible for that
um so to sum it up why do data products
fail uh either the work was not
sufficiently connected to customers
decisions
or the handoffs were not sufficiently
understood and established
and so when you're planning a data
product anything you're building for the
first time oops this slides are a little
bit messed up here but I'd say success
is directly proportional to how
specifically we can answer these
questions and the more you can answer
these questions ahead of time the more
likely your product will succeed right
and get very detailed into these whose
what decisions are going to be made
specifically with this work who is going
to take off take that hand off
specifically what are they going to do
how are they going to do it what are
they expecting from you and what are
they going to do afterwards whether it's
a person or a system
um and that's about it so yeah you can
grab the rest of this up here and thank
you very much
[Music]